black friday and
cyber monday may be getting most of the
holiday gifting focus but
small business saturday takes on a whole
new importance this year as many of
those businesses
struggle to stay afloat during the
pandemic for more on this cheryl cassoni
from fox business joins us now cheryl
always great to see you
uh okay so obviously it's been a
difficult year the most difficult year
in in many of these small businesses
history and they're about to have a
hopeful uh
maybe hopeful more upbeat moment in the
spotlight can you tell us about that
we'd like some good news
the more that we talk about it maybe the
better tomorrow will be for these small
businesses julia i mean according to
american express 64
of small business owners say tomorrow is
really make or break for them they
really are depending on that revenue to
come in
this means shoppers across the country
need to support those small businesses
tomorrow
i hope that it happens because look i
mean last year americans spent nearly 20
billion dollars
on small business saturday uh this is
the 11th year
uh that we've had small business
saturday and at this point
that ppp money that these guys got these
small mom-and-pop shops
didn't last very long we know that and
we also know that small businesses
are a huge driver of growth for jobs in
this country so it's not just about the
business owners
it's about the people that work for
those small businesses and this
year more than ever it's crucial that we
do that and i will say one thing to
encourage
folks to go to a small business tomorrow
is that if you're worried about going to
a mall
because of you know the chronovirus
you're worried about getting exposed
small businesses many of them across the
country have safety measures in place
that limit capacity
but in a small store that can be a good
thing and maybe people will feel a
little bit more safe to walk into that
shop
yeah i want to put the numbers into
perspective for our viewers if you take
a look at small business closures from
march first
when the pandemic really essentially
started here in the united states to
august 31st
nearly 164 000 small businesses have
closed due to the pandemic and also to
give you an idea of just how critical
small businesses are to americans
of the 31.7 million small businesses
nationwide
they employ 47.1 percent
of the private sector creating a 1.6
million jobs in 2019 so as we look ahead
what do you believe 2021 will look like
for small businesses
well it really depends on obviously
vaccine distribution it depends on the
economy it depends on jobs coming back
whether that's small or large businesses
if you work for a larger corporation you
have money to spend on that small
business
but the biggest question mark obviously
is going to be how severe these
new rounds of lockdowns are going to be
across the country it's still state by
state so that's that's
kind of tough for economists and
analysts to kind of quantify but i can
say that
if these lockdowns continue into january
um that puts them at a disadvantage
in in the beginning of the year having
said that i will say we are seeing a lot
of pent-up demand out there for folks
that are anxious to go out and spend
they're anxious to get back to their
restaurant
and their gym and their their friends
and family and having a social life
we're seeing that in particular here in
new york i mean i was looking at
unemployment here in the city it's
it's 14 and a half percent right now
there are stores all across the city
julia as you know because you live here
too
that are that are shuttered that are out
of business so it's two pieces it's
first off let's get this vaccine
distributed let's get that out there
which look probably march or april
before it's going to really be
more rampant right and then also let's
encourage folks to get back out
and support these small businesses
there's a lot of steps we have to get to
i will say
another round of ppp would be great i
mean that could really make a difference
and
okay give these guys a lifeline to hang
on until 2021.
all right so the 11th annual small
business saturday it's tomorrow
give back to your local businesses they
need it more now than ever cheryl
cassoni
thank you you bet john no